let's see if we can come up with the
equations for these different functions
function a b c and d
and i encourage you to pause the video
right now and try it on your own
so it might jump out of you that out at
you that these all look a little bit
like these all look a little bit like y
is equal to the square root of x which
would look something like this
and we've covered this in previous
videos y equals the square root of x
looks something
something like this except what we have
here all the other things look like at
minimum we flipped over the horizontal
axis and at least for b and d we flipped
over the horizontal and vertical axis
and in all the cases we have shifted it
so let's let's think about how we do
that so let's first flip over the
horizontal axis so where we would have
expected a positive y we're now going to
have a negative y so essentially we're
just going to do y is equal to the
negative square root of x to get
something that looks to get this thing
this is y is equal to the negative
square root of x
so put that negative in front of the
radical we flipped it over the
horizontal axis
so that is
y is equal to the negative square root
of x now let's think about how we can
shift this thing to look like function a
well function a there's two things about
function a that are different it's
shifted to the left by three and it's
shifted up it's shifted up by 1. and
we've seen this in previous and previous
examples if we want to get to a so i
could write a of x
what we could do to shift to the left by
3 we got to replace our x with x plus
three
so this is going to be negative square
root of x plus three that shifted us to
the left and then to shift up we just
have to add a one right over here so
that right over there is our a of x
that is our a of x
now let's think about b of x and
actually maybe i should move on this
side so that i can
clear my little scribbles right over
there
so that is our a of x now let's think
about b of x how is b of x different
than a of x
well b of x starts at the same point but
it's flipped over the vertical line x is
equal to negative three so it's or
another way of thinking this domain is
different this function's domain is x is
this is defined for x is greater than or
equal to negative three
b is defined for x is less than or equal
to negative three and we saw that also
in the previous video what we need to do
is flip the sign of everything that's
under the radical
so b of x
b of x is going to be equal to the
negative square root of
and going from a of x to b of x we're
going to flip the sign of everything
under the radical so it's the negative
x plus 3 and then once again we have the
plus
we have the plus 1 right over there
now to go from b of x to d of x is
reasonably straightforward we just have
to think we have to change how it's
shifted d is shifted relative to the
original function is shifted up by 3 and
to the left by 1.
so d of x
is going to look very similar to b of x
except it's shifting its shifting is
going to be different so let me just
write the part that is going to be very
similar to d of x it's negative
x plus
something and then plus something
d of x has been shifted relative to
square root of x to the left by 1. so
this is going to be x plus 1 and is
shifted up by 3 so it's going to be plus
just like that
and then finally c of x c of x
is just like
d of x except everything under the
radical everything under the radical has
to be has to have its sign flipped so it
is going to be it is going to be
negative
square root
of x plus 1 plus 3.
another way to think about it if you
wanted to go from a of x to c of x they
look very much the same except their
shifting is different
c of x is shifted up by three instead of
one so that's that difference and shift
it to the left relative to the square
root of x by one instead of three so
that's why we have x plus one instead of
x plus three the one thing i always want
to stress it's very intuitive that
changing this value if this if you make
this larger you're going to shift it up
if you make it smaller you're going to
shift it down but it's a little
counterintuitive that when you make this
value larger you're shifting more to the
left and when you make when you make
this value smaller or even negative you
start shifting more to the right and the
key when we go into this in some depth
in the previous video where we kind of
start talking about all of this but it's
just to think about especially relative
to square root of x when you think about
just y is equal to square root of x what
makes y equal zero what what what has to
happen under the radical first to be
kind of at the starting point right over
here well everything under the radical
has to be equal to zero and so you could
think about that same thing over here to
be at this starting point
everything under your radical has to be
equal to zero when does everything under
a radical equal zero at x equal negative
one well if everything under the radical
was x plus one so i encourage you to
think about that as deeply as you can
and to play around with things and then
hopefully it'll start making a little
bit of sense